about Gwyneth Paltrow who's on trial in
a civil case in Utah in connection with
a skiing accident back in 2016 the
oscar-winning actor was in court
yesterday She's accused of colliding
with another skier Terry Sanderson now
Sanderson claims he suffered a
concussion brain injury and four broken
ribs a witness to the Collision
testified about what he saw listen
and she just slammed him very hard I
mean very hard and so Terry she hits him
right directly in the bag and gwyneth's
on the top of him and to go down like
this and then Gwyneth hits him and then
bounces off and slides to the right
about five or ten feet did she ask if
Terry was okay
but she asked if Terry was hurt no
yesterday Paltrow's lawyer said it was
Sanderson who crashed into her outro
accuses Sanderson of trying to exploit
her wealth and her celebrity Sanderson
is seeking damages of three hundred
thousand dollars